uh
official comm ai uh attempting to
install a comma ai device
for 15 minutes
uh well it's uh 30. no well we've never
installed one on this car before we're
fast now like we're so fast on a toyota
but uh
still takes some time on a brand new
limited ram
1500.
um
this is all part of our project to
listen to the users
we're listening to users uh we want to
give you guys what you want
so we can sell more devices
the top consultants yeah on the users
the spokesperson for the users
uh no this is not an ev6
uh this is a ram 1500
one of our wait so this is different
from the pacifica yeah
oh that's so lame you think this is the
new one though yeah
even though this is a 2019 car
i don't think it's different in the new
rams it hasn't changed
it's different
you know what i think it's 2019.
um
well yeah so com is about to support a
truck uh if you do get this truck make
sure you buy it with the acc trim
i believe it's called like
active safety something
uh yeah so
are you googling how to take the trim
off
no i saw a video yesterday i gotta find
it again oh
maybe we should make videos for the
different cars
okay let me just link to them we already
have that youtube stuff set up on the
compatibility flow oh that'd be nice
yeah an install for your car yeah
yeah um but yeah so this is going to be
comma's first truck
um it's got a 400 watt outlet here
got usbc ports
oh that sounds like progress
oh or snapping
who's in the car does everyone wanna say
who they are
a researcher yeah we're we're all we're
here we're vehicle researcher
um we've got a whole bunch of vehicle
researchers here
yeah we just purchased this brand new oh
we just purchased this brand new combat
three at the comm ai shop
we cheaped out at the 250. uh we cheaped
out we didn't get a cross country
yeah check out the new case the new
injection molded case
super nice
got rid of all those little divots and
imperfections on the last one
the cameras fit perfectly yeah
if you buy a common three today you get
one of these
pretty much perfect cases
all right we have our trim removal tool
set here we're gonna make a red one for
the fourth of july i don't think so
here the ram is basically a luxury truck
all the trucks are expensive especially
when you get the four-door ones
like people think f-150s start at like
27 000 but it's the cheapest f-150 it
has two doors and has like nothing
um so yeah getting getting a super crew
cost some money
uh we made a custom harness for this car
um and apparently it doesn't have a
radar it only has four wires on the
harness so we're about to see if that's
actually true
drive it to nebraska what are we gonna
do in
nebraska's corn
[Music]
um
yeah guys no i'm serious we're trying to
expand into uh
right now like our top tier cars are
toyotas and hyundais
but um we think there's a big future in
subaru and chrysler as well
uh
maybe we'll buy uh buy a jeep grand
cherokee tail
yeah
yeah
and a pacific we need all the chryslers
are chrysler is good
we should get a waymo too oh should we
buy away now yeah
um all trucks are luxury yeah
people are happy with their pacificas
because it takes most turns
well so it's on all the pacificas now
it's standard on both the pacifica and
the new jeep grand cherokee
um but yeah common needed to get one
truck
so yeah we got we got a truck
there's lots of hood for this two
popular trucks
uh well i wouldn't go that far oh a fort
should be a good platform oh
gm and ford we found out how much money
the government pays them today
that goes what boeing and then gm
yup
uh
fast forward an hour that's worth it
fast forward an hour
finally after an hour
wow we're empathizing with the users
right now this is what the real uh
install experience must be like can you
invest in common not right now com is a
private company
ford's naming system for driver
assistance is so bad yes oh yes we have
we have co-pilot
co-pilot
co-pilot assist
and co-pilot active 2.0 oh and there's
the 2.0 and the non 2.0 it's worse than
usb but it's usb-c
high speed full speed
what
usb high speed full speed which one's
which one's greater the way i got it oh
usb yeah high speed is faster than full
speed i know that but then there's super
speed which is faster than everything
this guy's using a screwdriver always
using nylon pry bar
are you sure you want to pry
there you go
that didn't break it that sounded good
actually
should we hype up the rocket league
model
oh
yeah yo if you're on master i haven't
even tried it yet i have been driving
with torque control though i'm very
happy
i'm too lazy to merge the branches
i merged all the branches this morning
it drove on arnold driving on the ev6
with torque control
and end-to-end long with speed limits oh
yeah we have speed limits now the date
is not that good yet but oh you know
what i'm saying is like it's fine to
spend like a dollar of people's prime
fee to get them good speed limits
especially if we can get them not
navigating
steering is better you said
yeah oh yeah did we fix the ev6 steering
that's a lot better
what's wrong with taking the dash cam
mode if we find the last stupid bit
i'm gonna work on cars next week cool
yeah the ev6 is going to be in the next
release too
finally
after a lot of work
oh
the ram is the third most popular car in
the country
it's up there yeah well the trucks are
one two and three i don't i don't know
if there's two or three
i think it's f-150 and
then silverado
uh no i don't read the news
[Music]
i don't know i didn't realize taking
these trims off was so hard it's super
hard usually it's not this bad usually
it's not yeah
oh switch the cam yeah i got you
you gotta look at me
suspect you can just pull it down
oh that did not sound oh
wasn't good what
cricket it's all good
wow those clips are strong wait i think
you got one of the metals in there yeah
that's fine we could take that out yeah
it's their weighted but it's all good
man oh i see
oh these ones are usually easier
all right whoa look at this radar
oh the radar is right here
wow
okay so let's take a look is there
really only four wires on that that's
right here yeah there's four wires and
then why is there there's two to the
radar oh no it is the whole unit
no it is the unit
oh so this is not going to output wait
how does this work how are we going to
oh it's only using stock long yeah
ah is there only there's only four wires
on that connector
only c4 yeah
all right yeah
uh does it have always on power
let's see
oh yeah that's a good point
okay so the hardest part of your common
install is getting that piece of trim
off
once you've done that you connect the
convenient harness uh this one you
actually have to make sure to not put it
backwards because it's not a real
harness but all the ones sold in the
comma shop uh there's no way you can
plug them in
yeah yeah we'll we'll make him good by
the time
all right let's zoom out a little bit
here
let's see
20 plastic cover
all right do we have power we have to
connect the comma power
nope
i gotta connect the comma power
silver rock will reach out to you why
there's a second right lighter up there
oh oh also check in the uh in the glove
box there's some like weird uh or spare
parts that look like camera connectors
yeah
i don't really know this works
i don't understand that
you can just have people submit their
install for the car and oh yeah yeah
well we could just put them on the
website it's enough that we can do them
manually
all right are you okay
no blood no blood all right
oh it did snap that back plastic thing
too
no look at the back one
no on the back there yeah
is this something we're not doing right
maybe we should take a look at the uh
tech info
yeah
um there are two pieces of plastic
though
all right so then you connect your comma
power down to the obd port
someday cars are all going to ship with
obdc connectors
and now we should have power
nothing
nothing
the covers are very fragile wow casey
auto doctor those covers are very
fragile what do you mean specifically
the ram one
cool all right
great
we got power to our comma three
what's installed on here nothing nothing
brand new device from the shop all right
we just install stock master do we have
a special url for our internals
oh yeah we have a special url ah don't
show them the special url as a secret i
mean no just installs our keys so oh all
right
you can use this it just installs our
keys so it gives comma full access to
your device which you don't want and we
discourage
we're not tesla and we don't want to see
this now tesla got enough hate today no
hate on tesla today we love tesla
all right
let's go through the setup huh
do we have a sim card on that one
yeah
oh it's not
oh
oh oh oh now i didn't go through
fulfillment so we're going to have a bug
where it's like why did this one not
we now have a car and
oh no we're too far no
i want my free trial of prime
what is this car this is a ram 1500
and you're getting some of the best
people to set it up setting it up
and it's we're still struggling
never mind it's too hard
ram cancelled
take it back
what is the newest supported ev we're
about to support the ev6 which is
actually i really recommend the car i
think the prius is really the newest
important one could you say it was
supported before that shitty steering
the prius oh
oh yeah oh wait wait are you guys
driving the 2017 prius try out uh zero
eight fifteen
well we made huge changes uh
torque control finally works
you'll see you're the prius is night and
day
we're gonna delight people with the new
release
i was delighted with the speed limit
shane people happy with your work
eric likes the truck
i know i'm sorry it's not a toyota
how come installations has to wait 48
hours because
look if you want to mount it and you
want to go for one drive with it and you
take it down that's probably fine but
you really do want that the uh adhesive
to cure without weight on it
look is there any way around this
yeah what it's just gonna uh they don't
have these solutions you can put them
they have solutions yeah yeah
for the tape yeah yeah
oh we use it in the plastic always using
the tape of the plastic yeah yeah
especially use a bonder yeah
well we'll damage your windshield if we
do that yeah it's gonna stick a lot
stronger i think there's a removable one
too right
yeah there you can you can use chemicals
and
uh 815 is only for comma 3 yes
all right you want to go here you want
to install custom software
oh we have
openpilot.internal.com
it doesn't get you anything guys don't
install it
what is our url for master uh
installer.com
rumor comma 4 is coming out in november
i promise you it's not the next device
is called the 3s
uh it's not coming out this year and
it's not really an improvement over the
three except in manufacturing cost
i know you guys don't believe me when i
talk about new hardware anymore but
that's all true
ah
shane do we have a branch with the ram
stuff built in red panda on trace that
might happen
oh no but that doesn't have the ram
stuff
if you put up a bench
with something mm-hmm
do you want to push that let me try it
out
yeah know which one it is
no oh the common bots coming soon yeah
you guys we've been testing out the knee
and we got some we got some actuators
for arms this morning
but no arms are on hold we're really
just going to sell the body and the knee
for like a year
until we make at least i think it's 250
so we sell 250.
so we need to make 250 grand to uh
make the body project uh
we already beat elon elon put a guy in a
thing dancing okay
and gave vague promises they're gonna
show it off at ai today again
i heard i heard
the speed limit will be ready is speed
limit just pulling from a database yeah
it's pulling from map box and the
database isn't great uh we're definitely
not doing gonna do sign recognition i
can't even do that as a human
um
nothing about selling dancing people on
stage
uh you'll wait till the comet 3s plus
pro comes out
okay
uh no the commentaries are really good
the comic too sucked i can say it now
guys it was a phone in a 3d printed case
what do you expect
i mean they were good for what they were
they they you know they they didn't suck
compared to the eon
and the neo which managed to suck even
more
uh
no the the model does not run on our
server don't worry about that you think
you think it's uploading to our server
when can we see comma four there's no
plans for a comma four there is honestly
no plans for a comma four
what would we even put on it
we gotta figure out how to make devices
cheaper
plans for zero nine the taco toggle
this one is almost should we just call
this one zero nine
i mean we're close to the taco puzzle
we're close to the taco toggle yeah the
taco toggle is gonna be uh the big thing
with zero nine zero fifteen
though 0-8-15 torque control on the
optima is incredible
uh
0-8-15 is
shaping up to be yeah the nicest release
we've done in a long time
temperatures are going right down off
our power's gonna go way down
are you trying to get that clip out yeah
once this goes on we're never taking
them all
which cars can we do just over the obd
porn
yeah you want to merge master into that
control yeah
are there any cars we can do over just
the obd you have a bolt uh yeah i think
so volvo uses the obd2 harness i'll use
obd2 harness yeah of course oh wow if
that's the install yeah oh that's a
really nice install yeah
we use the obd200 we use the long usb
cable no but i think there's some other
astm
yeah they have to like take off yeah
it's not that great i wonder if on any
of these cars like i wonder if that one
can bus is uh
do we still need labeled data for dm yes
please go label it and comma pencil we
appreciate you
should we just close your eye 1509 it's
gonna have full frame dm
it's a big release
it is a big release but is that
multi-line
multiplier
well maybe i love the taco toggle too
i mean have we just tried the taco taco
yeah
not that great it's not that great
no idea that was the bug
that was just a bug we weren't parsing
the model outputs right
i've never used antenna long
but maybe the next rev of uh rocket
league model will just work hopefully
you think arm is going to be running ai
mostly in the future who's arm
oh like arm chips yeah bro risk
architecture changed everything
does it take so long to install
we're not close to wi-fi oh
can we put the download speed
yeah yeah
on the installer
yeah let's file
someone want to post an issue about that
if there's not an issue is there an
issue all right great oh not here you
want it in the act
i want it everywhere i hate just a bar
it's like what the hell is it doing oh
my
basically i know but still
it's not that hard to write
uh problem with using phones no the
problem with using phones actually the
variety in cameras is not the issue with
phones the variety of cameras is not
really an issue at all like we thought
it was an issue and it used to be an
issue with the old model but we do so
much augmentation now that you can like
put the dumbest camera into the open
model and as long as you get the
intrinsic somewhat correct it'll drive
the problem with phones is twofold
um one
uh they don't have the right cameras
uh so
the road facing camera is okay the dm
camera doesn't have any infrared uh and
you don't have enough you really need
the full 360.
uh so phones don't have the right
cameras um phones also don't have the
reliability
uh
even good phones
you're not you can't make a phone run on
the windshield and expect it to not fail
every year
a lot of this is because they do not put
the heatsink
right on the
processor the processor is on the other
side
yeah we're reinstalling a clip
imagine the future you could just dock
your phone and use it to drive a car
yeah i mean you could i think that
you're gonna you're better off going
with things that look more like common
bodies
um
as long as cars are still designed for
people i mean someday they won't be
designed for people but
you go back on
yes somehow
ways to make kama cheaper
well no i mean we can get down to the
price of phones uh
would i recommend the ev6
yes
you have to buy a red panda too though
[Music]
it all fits nicely on the cover though
so it's not too bad
on the ev6 if you spend like half an
hour i think nicely as a
if you don't have to put it in there
it's nice
it's a lot nicer than it inside oh did
we fix the usb do we hack around the usb
thing so we don't use that rtg cable
no
you could just get a long otg cable
though let's see why can't we just make
walkable cities guys stop trying to
change the environment for you change
yourself for the environment you'll be a
lot happier
uh ridgeline we don't have a ridgeline
we have a ram 1500. i don't know what is
the honda trucks like tiny yeah the
original is tight but we do support it
we just support it yeah
and it probably has uh you know 0.5
torques
we now have a system for measuring
torques
three is the maximum legally allowed
torques uh according to european
standards so a few cars have more than
three those ones are the only ones are
gonna be limited in panda everyone with
less than three
um you're allowed three torques and five
delta torques oh there's a new mdx
oh the airport
is so important
sell you a mirror mount no no you can't
sell mirror mounts nisha yelled at us
for mirror mounts
you don't do paramounts
um
i mean if you really don't want to see
it just put it up uh
just like shove it all the way up look
at that screen
all right guys i think that's a youtube
video
uh that is a comma ai install in a ram
it turns out it takes more like an hour
because we've been here for 25 minutes
and we still have another like
you know the power is pretty nicely done
um but yeah
uh we'll update you guys when the ram is
driving they should get into 015 which
might be zero nine as well uh any last
questions
um make sure to buy a comma three today
tell your friends buy a comma three
uh the toyota is a lot easier to install
yeah it's true is it hot in the truck
wow it's pretty chill san diego
yeah under a nice tree
tree in the shade
when is karma coming to rwanda i think
we shipped to rwanda
do we ship to africa uh the countries we
don't ship to are north korea and russia
we have blackness and iran
from iran
a
wrong
shipper maybe but no we don't ship
products to north korea iran or russia
we actually might not ship to china
anymore
oh yeah no china no china china's out
too look it's not because the other
three countries uh
china it's cause addresses are weird
libya
oh yeah no sorry libya
i don't know i've never like i've never
like
i i don't know anything about libya or
syria i've never considered going to
those countries
um
can we train it drive it without
training it in rwanda probably okay
do your roads look like decent if your
eyes look decent yeah
well sure i mean it depends where you
are in rwanda if you're in like rural
rwanda i don't know it's like a dirt
road i don't know if comma really works
on dirt roads if you're in a city i'm
sure it works
how powerful is the next comma going to
be it's not about power it's about the
software
if we devoted the whole company to
making everything work on the comma 2 we
could run everything on the comma 2.
we could sell a 10 adapter lens to give
you more
uh view forward
right that thing has a ton of uh
but you know you got to move forward and
that's why we have come three
um
it's all about the software it's really
all about the software the comma two can
probably drive a car
uh better than a human with like if god
wrote the software
i was like thinking if god wrote the
software how good could it be oh like
software is so far away from how good it
could be
uh when will comma come in a car
company's car package i'm not involved
with that that sounds boring
you're shipping rivian to brazil uh i
think we can run it
do we work with rivens
dorians have a bass i think they do
how many rivians are sold
probably not that many
four ravines hey that's still hey four
rivians are still more than the two
lucids that shipped
uh we could support all these cars it'd
be pretty easy i think
we should support tesla soon
as model three yeah
oh you got it yeah oh
yeah
[Music]
um why don't we advertise cause
advertising is for losers
uh
no seriously why don't we advertise
because like well i want
don't buy it you know you should buy it
and look you're watching an ad right now
look i'm an ad guys i'm an ad hi
uh can you put it on a tesla yeah we're
gonna
driver plus isn't great at all oh you
should try comma
um
yeah waste the money advertising i agree
uh no we're gonna support tesla i think
it's really gonna matter for tesla once
we get more some fsd style features
because like why would you spend 10
grand when you can just buy a comma
three and get like the same features and
i think the highway stuff's actually
better
it's probably already worth it on a
tesla without the fsd stuff yeah but it
won't sell as well right like there's
not many people who are going who ha
because autopilot comes with all the
teslas
yeah but someone mentioned comma going
bankrupt uh no bros it's true that's why
we just bought a new 50 000 car we
decided to you know
go out and style
in our ram 1500 yeah we have 1500 that's
right
um
now we're moving to a big new office
uh
kama's not profitable that's always sad
uh but that's just because we're
spending money on lots of stuff
no
wait
what do you say
well what before that
oh forgot it was something i had to come
back to i don't remember
oh uh
yeah oh is it already worth it on tesla
no i don't think so like autopilot's not
that bad on the highway no but there's
no wheel nag i think there's a big value
out the wheel nag is nice
um people love resume spam and i think
the wheel mag is just like a way worse
version of that yeah uh would we still
consider ourselves a startup yes
in many ways go full open source what do
you mean by that like the hardware open
source hardware helps chinese clone
makers and chinese clone makers
uh and that's it
we were profitable in the commentary
yeah we were quite profitable on the
commentator
uh we were a smaller team
the comma two had higher profit margins
than the comma three
how was the funding coming along for
toyota are we getting more votes today
nixon check on the votes right now
um
how are we gonna face challenges with
security locks oh my god you guys
uh actually no all the cars are going to
become secured and then com is just
going to have to close
yeah i don't know what to tell you
no no more no more oh you guys better go
buy votes you want us you want to see us
crack security go buy votes
what's wrong with chinese clone makers i
mean nothing we're fine with it we're
just not going to help them out like we
don't have a problem with them but
there's a difference between not having
a problem with someone and like helping
them out
um
all right like we can't we're not gonna
spend the r d and then just have clone
makers make exactly our stuff
uh can you order an empty case you can
go with our case
why can't it be cheap or well it's
expensive to make uh yeah someone in
combat just bought a tesla
uh so we're gonna support it i mean you
know he's gonna get fed up with the
wheel nag pretty soon
we can't drive you guys
why can't you drive it it's gotta
register
oh
what are my thoughts on blue box well
it's not real
like you can go give them money well
they just posted a video
what you seen no incredible video it
runs the model at like 2 fps oh sweet i
don't know why they didn't just uh it's
not even a car they could have just did
this on my pc
it looks like it's uh doing inference on
the device they posted a video of the
model running yeah
with the shittiest ui you've ever seen
oh i saw that on discord yeah look guys
if blue box is fine i like blue box i'm
rooting for them i'll tell you a few
things about the blue box though i have
a prototype
um
and
it has a two dollar camera sensor
uh
you can clearly see this in their video
too
yeah the camera sensor the omnivision
sensor in there costs two dollars
like our camera sensor is what 28 now
it's even more our camera sensor is like
35 now
right we spend more on lenses than blue
box spends on camera sensors so like
there's a reason it's expensive like you
can buy something cheap but you know
uh no i mean it's good and there's
definitely room at the bottom for open
pilot devices
uh you can ask about the body yeah would
the interior camera be used for dm no
the common three one can be used for way
more than dm
uh yes a lot of the silver and bronze
cars can be updated via software i think
we're gonna try to do the subarus and
chrysler as we'll see how far we can
push them for this release
rebel science that sounds political my
thoughts on politics are they're stupid
um how much does the commentary cost for
us to build about a thousand bucks
uh not including the cost of warranty
and support and shipping and yeah so now
you see why we don't make money on the
com3
what is it
oh i said we're gonna push up subaru and
chrysler to uh gold for this we're gonna
try oh yeah as far as we can yeah we
should be able to get the
bunch of subarus to gold uh are we going
to be able to get the chrysler skull
they can't steer down to zero
yeah we'll have to look into that any of
that configuration we can change the eps
yeah yeah we'll have to look into the
chryslers but i do think that subarus
are going to become gold soon yeah and
we'll add all these nice things like
resume spam
there'll be top tier experiences yeah
should we give a half star if we have uh
acc plus
plus yeah we offer acc plus on your cars
i think what's the real value after
people i definitely agree
it's not stock acc it's uh
somewhat uh the onyx tesla's honey grad
passed yeah we're gonna start using tiny
grad to run the model on the
device um and get rid of snpe on the gpu
can i explain how the rl driving model
works and why it's the future
no i can't
uh what about honda oh well
we're still installing it
yeah
we should just reverse actually and we
get one uh
that's our car right there use your
attack padawan i don't read the news i
haven't heard that
um
the news is stupid and designed to make
you stupid oh
uh where'd i cop the margiela hoodie i
don't know back up yeah
what happened oh you want to get on
wi-fi better yeah
is overpowered training exclusively on
common three data no we're still half of
common today i believe
but that's gonna change really soon
is there any value in junior dev
contributing to open pilot i mean i
don't know you gotta just
what's a weird question man
how much percentage is left on
installation it's done we just need to
like clean it up
that was it that was insulation
if we put the window down it'll get
better wi-fi i think the people should
know we check their resume before we
merge pr's
[Applause]
automatically that's right that's right
you got to be a senior dev if you went
to harvard
so if you open the garage you get faster
speeds
yo i put so many access points in the
new office we're never gonna have this
problem again
submit a pr and get grilled for it bro
exactly yeah if your pr sucks we'll just
close it without feedback
if it moderately sucks we'll give you
feedback and
if it mega sucks
if it's all if it's good then we'll
merge it
this is only one way to know if you're
good at something and that's to try
doing it
it's actually kind of true
uh it does not take this long to install
if you have release
if you buy a common three it's instant
uh it's just because we're installing
the internal branch which it also is
much much faster even on our internal
stuff if you have a wi-fi connection
that's decent which we don't
because the wi-fi is inside that metal
box over there
i think the axis is pointed
from the garage
it actually speeds it up i believe it
yeah
yeah tech padawan not only do i not read
the news i don't really want to hear
about the news
i'm going to open the garage and see if
the wifi gets fast
what happens if you invest in comma 2 3
and later models and come out and you'll
just be able to update old models via
software update i mean sometimes
the combat 2 no more but the combat 3
yeah should be software updates for a
while
we're going to be on this platform for a
long time well
probably it's still downloading
we have no wi-fi reception out here
yeah i'm still gonna do sub modules too
oh we have to it has to specify
kilobytes
is there a comma four in the pipeline no
legitimately there's not
uh what's in the pipeline is a cheaper
common three but probably only cheaper
for us not for you
uh with silver and bronze curves with
emergency break have longitudinal
support yeah we don't care about that
uh if we can support the longitudinally
well the problem actually why they don't
have a compound longitudinal is a lot of
them don't have radars
oh yeah no it won't stay open
man
uh we should just set it up inside yeah
all right guys thanks for watching the
video i just finished oh
oh oh oh now we gotta update agnos
oh great hey how come you guys made a
comment three if you said software's
important why not just keep updating the
comment too uh the comma two had a few
problems uh the cameras were not enough
uh to see uh they were both the front
camera was both not high resolution
enough and not wide enough
um we had no vision on the sides of the
car so you did need 360.
the other problem with the comma 2 was
it was very limited by how much heat it
could dissipate
because it was a phone in a plastic case
and the third problem was the
reliability they were unreliable and it
wasn't because of anything we did it was
just the phones aren't reliable
uh yeah we'll let it cure for 48 hours
it's not a joke guys like you can go for
one drive with it but then take it down
otherwise your thing's gonna fall off
after a year
all right
uh i've ended this movie like three
times like the lord of the rings uh so
uh
yeah rocket league models are all the
future
uh becomes a zero nine model yeah well
once it supports the taco taco you guys
know about the taco turtle red lights
stop signs slow down for turns all in
one toggle the taco toggle you're like
hobbit thanks bro